Bella Hadid and Kendall Jenner were  attacked by a fan in New York City I  mean it's so crazy to me  on Wednesday the model pals were heading  to gigi hadid apartment with a woman in  a great tracksuit bombarded them  the woman was waving a Palestinian flag  as she charged at Bella and she was  later handcuffed by police and taken  away it was just kind of an emotional  thing for me neither Bella nor Kendall  have responded to the incident on social  media and this isn't the first time one  of the Hadid sisters experienced a scary  fan encounter in public  Bella's big sis Gigi Hadid had to defend  herself during Milan Fashion Week back  in September after famous prankster  Vitaly sudoku lifted her by her waist  you